xavier fallières bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france peut être un mot
troisième nuit consécutive de
débordements qu'est ce qui s'est passé
cette nuit dans les villes aux pays-bas
toi qui te va bien falloir faire la
distinction entre ce qui s'est passé à
rodome samedi qui était d'une
manifestation tout à fait pacifique qui
a débordé à kozuka serait de hooligans
qui s'y sont joints et ensuite cette
flambée de violence qui n'a vraiment
plus rien à voir avec les les
restrictions soient bien dire légère de
confinement qu'on a en ce moment parce
que le confinement actuelle cesser ces
textes c'est extrêmement léger tout à
fait vivable il le faut parce qu'ici
dans les hôpitaux on va pas s'en sortir
si on continue comme ça donc je crois
qu'il faut bien faire la distinction
entre ce qui entre autres dans la
manifestation les départements la
manifestation pacifique de bredas en
oublie d'en parler et tous les
débordements de de ce week-end dans
diverses villes qui sont simplement des
rassemblements de casseurs et de gens
qui sont là pour la violence ça veut
dire qu'une grande partie de la
population néerlandaise finalement
acceptent ces mesures aujourd'hui tout à
fait on est sûr on va toujours être
confronté à ces 7 22 d'anti 22
complotistes conspirationnistes qu'on
écoute beaucoup trop quand je regarde
l'espagne et le portugal qui n'ont pas
ça ils sont solidaires ils sont tous
vaccinés il porte le masque et ils ont
quasiment plus de cas est ici on est
toujours en train de discuter sur la
base d'une hydroxy coquine qui peut-être
marcherait d'un vaccin qui ne marche pas
de chiffres des formes et mal interprété
ça ça et nous est à l'hôpital toujours
en train de travailler de plus en plus à
cause justement ces patients non
vaccinés alors justement quelle est la
situation très concrètement aujourd'hui
dans les hôpitaux néerlandais
alors si on regarde simplement les
chiffres on est à peu près j'irais
ailleurs dès ce matin à 2511 patients
hospitalisés dont 500 réa c'est par
rapport à l'année dernière on doit
continuer à faire les soins programmés
on peut plus annuler des interventions
on peut plus dire des à des gens avec
des cancers vous allez encore attendre
une semaine on peut plus dire à des gens
qui attendent depuis deux ans pour une
prothèse de hanche et ben ça va être
encore plus tard il faut qu'on continue
les soins et les soins sont bloqués par
tous ces gens non vaccinés qui occupent
les lie si on avait que les gens
vaccinés en réa des gens de plus de 70
ans aceh qu'il va que ça marche moins
bien ou ne marche pas trop bien ça on le
savait déjà ça serait pas du tout le
problème le problème c'est tout ce qui
s'ajoute à ça ce sont ces patients qui
refusent la vaccination et qui occupe
les lits et qui bloque tous ces soins
programmés sur lesquels on a déjà
parfois vingt mois de retard vous vous
dites que ce sont les non vaccinés qui
aujourd'hui sont hospitalisées
principalement aux pays-bas vous avez
des chiffres ah bah on a les chiffres
c'est simplement
c'est toujours dire oui mais il ya plus
de vacciner que de nom vacciner le jour
où 100% la population sera vaccinée on
aura très peu de cas dans les hôpitaux
misseron pour 100% vacciner quand je
regarde en réa c'est à peu près 66 70 %
de gens non vaccinés dans les services
il ya un peu plus de gens vaccinés qui
sont des gens avaient des comorbidités
énorme pour lesquels pour une simple
grille pour une grille grave ou un rhume
très grave peut-être qu'on est
hospitalisé pas en un problème que c'est
un virus ou il faut isoler les gens et
on les isole dans les hôpitaux et
sableux aussi des lits dont il faut bien
garder une certaine proportionnalité
entre des gens vaccinés qui sont âgés
qui ont tellement de maladies qu'ils ont
un espoir sur vic et des fois c'est
faible et quand on va dans des
obligations plus jeunes on tombe
uniquement sur des gens non vaccinées en
france on parle beaucoup dans les
hôpitaux de manque de moyens de manque
de lits quelle est la situation aux pays
bas et un manque de moyens également il
ya il ya un problème ça fait dix ans
qu'on ont fait des progrès technologique
énorme donc on a de moins en moins
besoin de lits on a de moins en mois de
grosses interventions qui ont besoin
dans leur règne est en réanimation on a
de moins en moins accidents de la route
donc on a de moins en moins besoin de
lits on a des turn over patients
en ambulatoire qui sont énormes donc
c'est sûr qu'il ya maintenant une
inadéquation entre une crise sanitaire
et un besoin de lits et les lits est
tellement disponible sur un lycée avec
du personnel autour assez pas seulement
un lit avec des draps ça ça sert pas à
grand chose donc c'est pas tellement le
problème on a un manque crucial de lits
pour une situation normale c'est un cri
syndicats que ça passe plus vous parliez
tout à l'heure de mesures assez désert
finalement de confinement remise en
place aujourd'hui pour autant elles sont
indispensables
pourquoi
parce que il sait très bien pour
l'instant le virus d'alter bailly le
variant delta cours à très grande
vitesse il se rend très très vite chez
les gens vaccinés il se transmet aussi
on sait bien l'avantagé que quelqu'un de
vacciner bat contre le virus en lui
beaucoup moins entend
donc il va falloir est allé et pouvoir
gérer la crise on sait très bien
maintenant certainement l'immunité
hybride donc le coc vite plus
vaccination ou linverse vaccination et
avoir le coc vide est certainement le
meilleur moyen d'obtenir une immunité
solide mais il faut l'étaler dans le
temps ce tout en sachant que les gens
âgés par risque d'atterrir à l'hôpital
et d'encombrer des 10 et si on a des
gens nous vacciner en plus on s'en sort
on nous on a vu ces dernières semaines
ce débat autour du confinement des non
vaccinés notamment avec la situation en
autriche est ce que la question se pose
aujourd'hui aux pays bas on en parle on
parle plus du système un g2 g3 j'ai dans
le sens de vacciner guéri ou interdits
ou tester et de plus en plus on va vers
un système deux géants pour vacciner
aide au freinage qui veut dire soit les
gens ont été vaccinées soit ils ont un
certificat de rétablissement six mois et
bientôt un an et les autres de ne
pourront plus aller dans les restaurants
dans les bars dans les cinémas etc
devront cacher chez eux c'est une espèce
de confinement des noms matinée où c'est
ce qui va arriver à un pass sanitaires
un peu à la française finalement non
pire c'est à dire que les gens testés ne
pourront même plus aller dans les
restaurants etc en france vous dis-je
comme si vous toujours ouverte et c'est
vrai il obtenir passe encore et ça
infini
merci beaucoup xavier fallières pour
votre ce matin sur rtl france sur la
situation sanitaire aux pays-bas et des
émeutes qui ont éclaté pour la troisième
nuit consécutive